listen the met gala for attacks original
layers here's the thing with this the
met gala they always wear [ __ ] that you
could never wear and you can you just
wear it once what is it like where's
pete dave's gonna wear that again where
the [ __ ] you gonna wear that dress again
dude but what is it what is it for me
gal is like the big fashion like i think
it's 55 000 a table something like that
it's so expensive it's just a fashion
show to have rich people jerk each other
but the rich people wear [ __ ] like like
they're wearing horns with diamonds like
you're never going to wear that it's
like well high fashion is like you never
see high fashion ever that correlates to
the real world yeah
never it's crazy and look at aoc
meanwhile she's rich and she paid 55
grand to be there so they just wear the
outfit once that's jlo i mean god damn
jayla killing it mm-hmm fifth okay she
looks stunning that's what i'm saying i
mean look at this hey hey
yeah
i'm all in i'm all in there just go to
show like you know when you got money
like i wonder how much she spends on her
body like getting herself you know
trainers chefs uh you know what i mean
she got probably got a cryo we got an
oxygen thing in her place does she look
good or what yeah
oh see that's good too she's just crazy
they all look good and then and then uh
kim kardashian she always has to do
something super crazy what does she do
like everybody else dresses all normal
and she's like you know what i'm gonna
take another dude
[ __ ] nick
why kim's the one in the black mask i
don't know why the kardashians get so
much hate like kim kardashian she ain't
regular fine
she's fine
yeah
is she really that funny yeah man she's
just something she got something about
her let me see her you know what you
know what it's kind of crazy but let me
see the butt
let me see the kardashian
you know you know you know what's weird
though is with travis scott uh getting
with kylie jenner right
she's flying too now now now but god
don't play that plastic surgeon [ __ ]
like that like remember she was a basic
ass white girl before all these
surgeries then travis scott has a baby
with her that baby comes out doesn't
look nothing like her she has so much
work done
who wore it better
[Laughter]
that's just for publicity right they
want attention she yeah should do
anything
tax the rich meanwhile the rich pay for
all your taxes yeah that's what ken wore
okay so that's okay
and kanye were the same thing that
like they got a weird relationship huh
the weirdest you know yeah you think
they still booty calling every now and
then oh yeah imagine showing up to an
event like this all right
do they have normal butts do they get um
did they get operations
all four so how do they get their butts
bigger they inject some kind of inject
fat they take fat from their tummies to
put in their ass okay damn i just want
to do that but i put it all in my dick
just a big fat ass dick that i can't
even control
yeah i think uh but i think that i think
women you should put a poll for that
because i think women would say
thickness over length they don't want
you because it's real long and skinny
like a twizzler you ain't doing a [ __ ]
yeah you're gonna hurt somebody's inside
how thick do you want it though
i mean you know like no i don't know
like like like red bull can't think like
a red bull you know the right thing
dude liquid death dick yeah
that's too much
you want red bull can't think red bull
can't but what size what how many ounces
the eight or the twelve i want it to be
where i can't even wear a swimsuit
because people are gonna be like yo yo
yo yo you hanging
you're scaring all the kids yeah i want
to constantly be poking
look like gonzo in a ski mask
but how long do you want it what's
too long
over 12 inches oh dude that's insane
what are you going to do with you want
to kill somebody with that i eat if if
it's thick enough as long as you're
around six i'd say
yeah is that good six i mean i don't
know what about five and a half yeah we
gotta get the we have to get the we have
to get the female cats uh people to like
let us know it's five and a half okay
it's all good
like where are you gonna
where are you gonna wear that again just
do this we're the first
fabulous he is he is just fabulous
like good for him
he's leaning into this stuff although he
has a lot of sugar in it that takes cuts
man he's really doing it does it
yeah man that's it how can you walk
that's his thing
yeah this dude's a queen of england
right now
[Music]
is
[Music]